elle se définit comme une salariée
lambda une madame tout le monde fière de
représenter les Français à l'Assemblée
mon invité revendique d'ailleurs son
côté novice en politique elle en fait
même sa marque de fabrique
[Musique]
bonjour C'est Golan Amiot bonjour alors
votre toute première prise de parole
dans l'hémicycle n'est pas passée
inaperçue c'était juste après la
déclaration polémique de l'ancienne
secrétaire d'État Caroline cailleux qui
avait voulu justifier son hostilité au
mariage gay tout en se défendant d’être
homophobes on va revivre ça en images si
vous le voulez bien puis je vais vous
dire quand même que j'ai beaucoup d'amis
parmi tous ces gens là et franchement
c'est un mauvais procès qu'on me fait et
ça m'a beaucoup contrariée madame la
Première ministre je suis de ces gens là
la liste des déclarations homophobes est
trop longue déchu Darmanin et bien sûr
cailleux qui affirme toujours son mépris
des homosexuels je vous le rappelle au
cas où mesdames et messieurs les
ministres l'homophobie n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit
alors on sent de l'émotion forcément
dans votre voix ce jour-là tout est
parti de cette expression ces gens-là
que emploi Caroline Cayeux qu'est-ce
qu'elle porte en elle pour vous cette
expression en fait au-delà de
l'expression c'est jean-là c'est de dire
ce sont des gens qui ne sont pas moi ce
sont pas des autres moi mais au-delà de
ça c'est ce qu'on entend souvent je ne
suis pas raciste j'ai un ami noir je ne
suis pas homophobe j'ai des amis gays
on en est encore là en 2022 de dire à ce
moment-là 2022 mais on en est encore là
à se dire à se défendre d'être homophobe
parce qu'on a des amigaies
ostraciser enfin c'est pas tant moi que
le fait que on a encore à apprendre de
ce que ça signifie que d'être homophobe
que c'est pas forcément déclaré de la
haine envers l'autre mais de faire une
différence entre les uns et les autres
et c'est pareil pour le racisme et
toutes les autres formes de
discrimination alors quand vous dites je
suis de ces gens là vous revendiquez
évidemment votre appartenance à la
communauté LGBT je crois que vous-même
vous vous définissez comme pansexuelle
alors je suis pas sûr que tout le monde
sache exactement ce que ça veut dire ce
que nous l'expliquer en quelques mots en
quelques mots pansexuelle c'est que je
n'ai pas de
d'attache au corps des gens ce qui ce
qui va m'attirer chez quelqu'un c'est
qui il est qui elle est sans
discrimination de son genre exactement
donc en vrai je tombe amoureuse de
personnes parce qu'elles sont belles à
l'intérieur hommes ou femmes ce jour-là
donc à l'Assemblée vous avez pris la
parole sur le sujet qui est à l'origine
de votre tout premier engagement public
vous avez été vice-président du Centre
LGBT de Nantes qu'est-ce qu'il y a
motivé votre démarche à l'époque
pourquoi vous avez décidé de vous
engager
j'ai décidé de m'engager parce que j'ai
eu la chance de déjà d'être accueilli
par ce Centre LGBT au moment où moi-même
je me posais des questions sur mon
orientation sexuelle et que j'ai j'ai
constaté que il y avait besoin de coup
de main tout simplement pour aller
expliquer aux jeunes c'est quoi la
discrimination et comment ce combat vous
en sortez dans l'hémicycle c'est le
premier combat que vous avez porté dans
le cadre de cette association là est-ce
que vous-même vous aviez été victime de
discrimination j'ai été victime de
discrimination au départ par des petits
mots des serveurs de café ici à Paris
qui parce que je venais d'embrasser ma
compagne nous demande de sortir parce
qu'on est un établissement respectable
madame donc voilà ce genre de choses
jusqu'à vivre l'agression d'une autre de
mes compagnes en plein centre-ville de
Nantes et tout ce qu'on peut vivre au
quotidien de non mais c'est que tu as
pas rencontré le bon mec ou
[Musique]
de comprendre pourquoi est-ce qu'on
avait tout cassé et de me rendre compte
que je n'avais plus les outils à ma
disposition en tant que syndicaliste
pour défendre mes collègues pour porter
des affaires
en fait j'ai plus de
politiquement là j'ai plus les outils
pour aider le seul moyen de faire
changer les choses c'est c'est
politiquement c'est de faire changer les
lois et donc je me suis engagé en tant
que militante pas en tant candidate je
me suis engagé pour
pour aider en l'occurrence une candidate
à devenir elle-même députée donc ça
c'est à peu près 2017 campagne de 2017
vous n'êtes pas candidat vous êtes
militante au sein de la France insoumise
et puis vous vous présentez en 2022 vous
êtes élu députés vous l'employez donc
d'un centre d'appel téléphonique je le
disais vous êtes plusieurs aujourd'hui à
représenter une France qui avait pas
trop sa place jusqu'à présent dans
l'hémicycle est-ce que vous le ressentez
comme une responsabilité ça fait peser
un poids sur vos épaules en tant que
député aujourd'hui en fait
au-delà d'un poids j'espère que ça va
devenir un étendard c'est-à-dire que
j'aimerais vraiment que les jeunes de
nos quartiers que les femmes que les
personnes
lambda comme moi
intègre et accepte que la politique ça
nous appartient aussi ça nous appartient
à toutes et tous et qu'il faut
absolument s'en saisir que et ça donne
envie à d'autres de faire comme vous je
souhaite je le souhaite et je vraiment
je milite même pour ça pour que chacun
s'approprie les questions politiques
alors vous on l'a entendu vous parlez de
salariés lambda vous utilisez souvent
l'expression madame tout le monde ou
noob nous ça veut dire quoi ça une
expression de geek une expression de
joueurs de gamer de jeux vidéo de jeux
vidéo exactement ça veut dire qu'on
vient de commencer on connaît pas un peu
enfin on est débutant on débute
exactement est-ce que ce côté débutant
donc ou novice en politique est-ce que
ça veut dire que vous avez une façon de
faire de la politique différente je le
pense dans le sens où j'ai pas forcément
les codes enfin voilà on est ici à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a des codes
il y a des des façons de faire des
façons de se tenir de s'habiller de ce
de se parler que j'ai pas parce que j'ai
pas grandi dans ce milieu là et donc ça
se traduit comment dans votre aussi dans
votre action politique est-ce que c'est
différent parfois j'enfonce des portes
que je devrais pas enfoncer
je crois qu'une des toutes premières
questions que je me suis posée en
arrivant ici et que j'ai posé
tous les gens que j'ai pu rencontrer
c'est est-ce que quelqu'un numéro de
téléphone du ministre de l'Éducation
ça a surpris ça a choqué ça
qu'on fonctionne machin et donc j'ai
demandé à mon assistant qui qui le
pauvre était tout seul en plus pour
m'aider à ce moment-là ça faisait 48
heures que j'étais élue ici débrouillé
il a trouvé un moyen de le contacter
vous avez réussi à agir sur un dossier
avec avec votre
ce regard totalement neuf presque neuf
sur la politique que vous avez s'il y a
des choses qui vous ont choqué quand
vous êtes arrivés à l'Assemblée déjà le
décorum et quand j'ai des Corum c'est
pas uniquement le bâtiment
et le faste c'est-à-dire parce qu'on le
voit un peu ça quand même aussi les
palais de la République on en parle
souvent mais en fait c'est tout ce qui
va autour le fait d'avoir énormément de
d'administrateur énormément les
huissiers
qui sont là pour nous aider nous
accompagner et
finalement de constater la quantité de
personnes qui sont là pour nous aider
d'une manière ou d'une autre pour nous
rendre la vie la plus facile possible et
notre exercice le plus le plus aisé
possible ça m'a évidemment interpellé
puisque jusqu'ici que ce soit dans
l'espace syndical ou dans ou dans
l'espace associatif à chaque fois qu'on
avait besoin de quelque chose c'était à
nous de le faire 100% et effectivement
avec des bouts de ficelle enfoncer les
portes surtout qu'on nous m'attendais
pas où vous voulez pas nous forcément là
où on allait donc fallait y aller quoi
alors le revers de l'engagement c'est
qu'on devient la cible de ses
adversaires et que les attaques sont
parfois très éloignées du terrain
politique le 15 octobre 2022 vous avez
découvert un message posté sur Twitter
par Gilbert Collard qui a utilisé une
photo de vous dans l'hémicycle prenant
la parole accompagnée de ce texte
regardez cette député nuque qui donne de
sa personne pour la transparence à la
Chambre comment est-ce que vous avez
réagi quand vous avez vu ça j'ai utilisé
beaucoup de gros mots soyons honnêtes
quand j'ai quand j'ai découvert ça
et puis surtout ça réveillait une autre
colère c'est à cause de ma personne et
c'est pas grave enfin voilà
en soi c'est tout le mépris qui avait
derrière le mépris à la fois de classe
le mépris sexiste grossophobe vraiment
tout le mépris qui venait me dire tout
simplement que je n'avais pas ma place
dans l'hémicycle et qui venait dire à
tous les gens et pas que les femmes
d'ailleurs
tous les gens qui qui d'une manière ou
d'une autre peuvent s'identifier se dire
moi aussi je peux être à cette place là
un jour et ben dans ce tweet dans ce
message Gilbert Collard venait leur dire
que non ils n'ont pas leur place et ça
c'est une violence extrême la violence
ça aussi est-ce que ça a été des
messages que vous avez reçu après il y a
eu des comment comment ça s'est passé
des messages tout ceci
dégueu les uns que les autres
viols des menaces de de meurtre
des avis évidemment sur non pas ce que
je suis ou ce que je représente mais
mais qui je suis et ce que je devrais
faire et de mon argent et de mon temps
et de
préparer à cette forme de violence qui
est peu existé malheureusement politique
non honnêtement non d'autant plus que
c'est pas ma façon de de faire je suis
jamais dans l'attaque à nominé et encore
moins sur sur le physique des gens
donc bon la fin de l'émission C'est
l'heure de notre petit quiz je vous
explique le principe je vais commencer
une phrase et ça va être à vous de la
compléter ok on y va depuis que je suis
député mes anciens collègues de la
plateforme téléphonique pense que
vous êtes loin vous n'êtes pas assez
c'est sûr et que vous-même vous
n'arrivez pas à les voir ah non j'en ai
revu quelques-uns fort heureusement des
vrais amis et mais c'est compliqué à
l'Assemblée tout s'arrange quand tu
comprends que que t'es pas tout seul
au début vous vous sentiez un peu seul
ou que en fait collectivement on arrive
à faire tellement plus de choses que ce
soit au sein de nos groupes politiques
ou en transpartisan ou vraiment
c'est assez fabuleux ce qui me manque le
plus depuis que je suis député c'est du
temps du temps du temps pour faire pour
voir mon mari pour faire un peu de sport
pour ne pas faire de politique et pour
faire de la politique il me faudrait des
journées de 50 heures pour conclure vous
disiez que vous aviez voulu devenir
député pour changer la loi sauf que bah
là vous êtes dans l'opposition vous
changez pas vraiment la loi est-ce que
finalement vous dites pas que vous
auriez été plus utile en restant
syndicaliste dans votre entreprise non
je me dis pas ça en vrai parce que vous
avez trouvé une autre utilité j'ai
trouvé une autre façon effectivement de
d'exercer mon mandat aussi parce qu'on
travaille quand même à construire des
lois de façon transpartisanale aussi et
qui a d'autres façons que que d'apporter
un texte tout fait dans l'hémicycle il y
a aussi d'aider à la construction du
texte et du coup là on peut déjà
apporter sa pierre d'une part par les
amendements mais aussi en amont mais il
y a aussi le fait de pouvoir pouvoir
faire changer des petites choses par ci
par là parce que parce que j'ai un
mandat parce que j'ai une écharpe
tricolore parce que quand on appelle un
n'importe qui en disant madame la
députée souhaiterait vous rencontrer ça
fait changer des choses parfois et puis
parce que on continue à construire un
parlement plus à gauche et peut-être que
prochaine élection on sera très bien
amoureux exactement merci beaucoup
Ségolène Amiot d'être venu dans la
politique et moi avec plaisir
[Musique]